a famous explorer once said the day
extraordinary and what we do not who we
are
the last two and a half years I've been
working on a game called tomb raider and
I am the voice and character of the
iconic British heroine Lara Croft the
2-meter franchise has taken back I had
taken two meter and they're rebooting it
so we're going back to when Lara was 21
years old and she's just a normal 21
year old adventurous inquisitive young
girl and maybe even a bit naive and 2
meter takes her on a journey of where
she's just pushed to my limits she's in
a nightmare situation and you really get
to see how she became the now iconic
Lara Croft everyone knows her love
I've been doing the motion capture for
the past two and a half years and I've
also been doing the voice-over in an ad
RB you enter what they call the volume
and a massive room that has cameras
everywhere surrounding the entire room
and you put on a helmet that has a
camera right in front of your head and
you spend the day rolling around playing
with guns getting beaten up if you're
Lara Croft
every day I would walk away from filming
and have bruises all over me and it was
great because I couldn't tell anybody
that I was Lera Kraft and that's what I
was doing so everyone be saying like
well how did you get those bruises on
back oh I just walked into a door again
for the 20th time this week and so I
think I just looked especially clumsy
for two and a half years because I was
just covered in bruises and can't tell
anyone what it was wrong